-My first guest is one of my
all-time favorites.
He's the funniest human.
He's so talented.
I love the guy.
He stars --
stars in and co-wrote
the new movie "Hubie Halloween,"
which premieres
October 7th on Netflix.
It is awesome, it is funny,
it is scary.
Here is Adam Sandler.
-Yes, Jimmy. Yes, yes.
-This is what I'm talking about.
-Jimmy.
-This is what --
-You look good.
You look handsome.
-Thank --
Thank you very much.
I appreciate that.
You look good, too.
You got the beard going.
-Yes. Just covering a lot of --
lot of chins.
Lot of chins came in.
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
Had to really --
had to really grow this one long
to block those suckers.
-Thank you for being on the show
again, Zooming.
You were on, helped me out when
we were first starting out,
and I appreciate that.
-Yes.
-Are you getting used to Zoom?
-Zoom is --
I don't love Zooming as much as
everyone else 'cause the --
It's hard to hang up
on Zoom because people --
I'm good at hanging up on the --
on a cellphone.
You know, pretending I got into
a car accident or something
and just pressing end.
But Zoom, you got to literally
look at somebody and go,
"I -- I've had enough of this."
-[ Laughing ]
-"This is too much, man.
I don't want
to be around you anymore."
-Yeah.
"Our conversation's over."
And you go,
"Wow. Really blunt."
"Saturday Night Live" is --
season premiere is this weekend.
They're back, live, at 30 Rock.
-Yes.
-Our buddy, Chris Rock,
is hosting.
-Yeah.
Isn't that nice that they --
that Lorne was like, "You know
who'd be great for this time?
Old Chris Rock."
He -- He --
I was talking to Chris
a couple of weeks ago,
when he was thinking of hosting.
And I was very, like,
"There's nobody like you, buddy.
You have to do that."
He was excited.
And --
-Perfect.
-You know his monologue
is gonna be incredible.
How about Rock,
anything he says,
even in conversation, you go,
"There's no way
I would have thought of that,
ever, in my life,
but that's so on the money."
Everything he says
is so on the money,
but you're just like, "Wow.
How did I not ever
think that way?
That's incredible."
-Well, you've known him
since stand-up, right?
Did you guys
do stand-up together?
-Yes, I knew Rock.
We know each other
since 17 years old.
Just like you.
You started real young, too.
I was just a young baby,
and I was kind of known
as the young guy in comedy.
And then,
I got to The Comic Strip,
and they kept -- Lucien,
who ran The Comic Strip...
-Yeah, Lucien Hold, yeah.
-Lucien Hold kept saying,
"You and Chris Rock,"
and I kept saying,
"Who's Chris Rock?
What do you keep bringing this
other guy up to me?"
And they're like, "Well, he's
out with Eddie Murphy right now.
Eddie Murphy loves him,"
and I was like,
"Eddie Murphy likes somebody,
not me?"
I was so upset.
-[ Laughs ]
-And then --
And then, Rock came to the club
after hanging out with Eddie.
And he came to the club,
and we met.
And we just became
really tight immediately.
I was like,
"Oh, man, this guy is funny."
You know, I saw him --
I saw Rock like
10 years ago in Vegas.
I went with Nicholson --
me, Nicholson, and Jim Brooks.
-Wow.
-And I sat in between
Nicholson and Jim Brooks,
watching Rock,
and, literally, every time
I looked left or right,
Nicholson was doubled over
and Jim Brooks was doubled over,
and I was going, "I wish Rock
could see this, man,"
'cause we were a few rows back,
and he was not getting to see --
Imagine getting to see
Jack Nicholson and Jim Brooks
thinking you're the funniest guy
on the planet.
Anyways, that was cool.
-Also, the thing I love
about Jack,
and you know this, too --
he laughs the way he talks,
kind of.
Like, he goes like,
"Ha, ha ha, ha!
Ha ha!"
[ Laughter ]
I'm like...
That's how he laughs.
-Yeah.
-I want to talk about
"Hubie Halloween."
-Yeah.
Why not, Jimmy?
-In a different --
to shift gears,
you dedicate the movie
to the late Cameron Boyce,
who was supposed to be
in "Hubie Halloween,"
but he, sadly, passed away
before filming.
-Yes, just a few days
before filming,
and that kid was a great kid.
Just such a --
His family's amazing.
I know him from "Grown-Ups."
He was a little kid
in "Grown-Ups,"
and I watched him grow up
and become, like, a superstar.
My kids worshipped him.
Every ki--
He came to my daughter's
bat mitzvah.
-Really?
-And he came
and literally signed -- I mean,
that bat mitzvah was gigantic.
There were like 400 people there
and massive amount of kids.
And he signed
every kid's autograph,
and everybody was freaking out
over Cameron.
And he was just the nicest kid.
And he always
had charities going on
and always would speak to me
about, "Can you do this?
Can you do that?"
It was always for charity.
He didn't care
about anything else.
And just a nice,
solid, talented kid.
You know, like, when he was
a little kid --
Remember in "Grown-Ups,"
the "I want to get
chocolate wasted"?
-Oh, yeah.
-It was like the --
the little girl said that,
Alexis says that.
And -- And I think --
-"I want to get
chocolate wasted."
-Yeah.
She won, that year,
like, an MTV award,
Funniest Line or whatever,
and she got the award.
But Cameron said it around the
table when he was ad-libbing,
and everyone laughed.
And then,
he said it a couple times,
and I go, "Cameron, you mind if
the little girl says it?
Might be funnier."
And he was like, "Okay."
[ Both laugh ]
And then --
And then, she did it.
Blah, blah, blah.
And then, after, I go,
"Cameron,
I can use yours or hers.
Whatever you want."
He goes, "Whatever --
Whatever's funniest, man," but
kind of like, "I'll kill you."
And then,
the next thing you know,
the nice little girl gets --
And I saw Cameron years later.
I go, "That 'chocolate wasted,'
that's still bugging you."
He's like, "You owe me."
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, that's awesome.
That's cool.
I didn't know
that he wrote that.
That's cool.
"Hubie Halloween."
Is this your first
holiday film for Netflix?
-Yeah.
Yeah.
They wanted to make
a holiday movie.
I knew Chris--
if I made a Christmas movie,
people would say, "No, no, no.
I'm not buying that, buddy."
So I said, "Let's go Halloween.
Let's go Halloween on you."
-So many funny people in this --
in this movie.
I mean...
-Yes.
-So many funny people.
Tim Meadows, Maya Rudolph.
-Yes.
Yeah, Kenan.
-Kenan's great.
Shaq is in it.
Shaq's very funny.
-Shaq's incredible.
Dan Patrick is in it!
He yelled at me this morning!
He says I never mention
that he's in the movies.
Dan Patrick.
-I'm sorry.
We had to
edit that out for time, but...
[ Both laugh ]
-That was good, Jimmy.
Dan is hilarious in it!
Thank you, Dan.
-[ Laughing ]
I want to show a clip.
Here's Adam Sandler
in "Hubie Halloween."
Take a look.
♪♪
-[ Muffled shouting ]
-Michael Mundie.
-Listen, I am a fan of Halloween
zingers as much as the next guy,
but --
-[ Muffled shouting ]
-What?
What are you saying?
-[ Muffled shouting ]
-Michael?
Michael!
♪♪
What d--
-[ Screaming ]
-Adam, thanks again
for coming on the show.
You're the best --
-Does it get better than that?
Does it get better
than that clip, Jimmy?
-No.
-Oh. Right?
-The only way it can get better
is if it's a whole movie.
-Yeah, that's it, man.
-Adam Sandler, everybody.
"Hubie Halloween" premieres
October 7th on Netflix.
Check it out.